Lindsay Levin: So we're living in an era
with multiple overlapping disruptions
that business is facing,
and I want to dive straight in
and talk about one of the biggest
of those, which is AI.
How are you approaching AI?
Paul Hudson: You know, AI at scale,
it's a whole big subject, of course,
but for us, at Sanofi,
we aim to be the world's leading
pharmaceutical company using AI at scale.
Why and how are we going to do that?
It's pretty straightforward.
We have 23,000 people using AI
as often as every month,
9,000 people in the company
using AI as often as every day.
We're boldly taking on the opportunity
to completely disrupt the business.
We don't have a choice.
It's the fourth industrial revolution.
It's here whether we like it or not.
And it's amazing how resistant people
can be across organizations
and across industries.
But we're all in and have been
quite public about that.
Our aim is to provide
daily decision intelligence,
to give people a sort of nudge
in the right direction,
to give them deeper insights,
to allow them to be more
effective at what they do.
And it's real.
And it's such a privilege
to be involved in it.
LL: I mean, you're taking
a very aggressive, active stance.
What surprised you?
PH: Well, a lot of things
surprise you about AI.
I mean, for some people
it's Skynet and Terminator.
For some people,
they confuse AI with cyber.
I'm not saying everything is perfect,
but I'm surprised at the number
of CEOs or executives who --
Their first response
to an AI conversation is
"Governance, controls, rules, principles."
Of course, everything has its place,
but I think we have to be
honest with ourselves.
If it is the fourth industrial revolution,
which we believe it is,
then hesitating,
this fear that can take over,
can deprive you of so much opportunity.
And you have to go for it.
I find that when you talk to lots of CEOs,
they really are very hesitant.
Some would say even frightened.
I look internally,
people are frightened that you get
this radical data transparency
You can see their data real-time.
LL: And you're experiencing that.
PH: I've experienced that and still do.
You know, people are often shocked
that you may get the insight
at the same time
as somebody lower down the organization.
And then there's the lost opportunity
to polish a slide deck
and re-present it in the way
that I'm supposed to be informed.
It's not a deliberate,
sort of, misleading approach.
It's what people know.
They get the insight,
they craft the story,
they push it upwards.
And that's life in many corporations.
For us, we get the data,
I get the same data every level
of the organization does.
I get the insight exactly the same time.
And then people say, "Paul, don't look,
the data is not 100 percent correct."
Well, make it correct
because the data is live.
So if you really jump in
and make it correct,
it'll better reflect
what you're doing, right?
But if we wait for perfection
it's simply not going to happen.
LL: So we're seeing fear and some
of that, I guess, is not unreasonable.
You know, we read reports
about the impact on job losses,
for example,
to come from AI.
I wonder what mindset you believe
people need to adopt
in the workforce of all generations,
as they approach or we all
approach this new future?
PH: You know, the adoption
of AI in particular is not about jobs.
And I know people will think that
and inevitably, more meaningful
work is created.
And of course, some roles change
or some skills don't match.
And therefore, you know, with the help
of many of the people in the room,
you get to reshape organizations.
But in the end,
it's really about using
artificial intelligence
to create this real momentum
of decision making
and to be able to take such an advantage
over the competition.
And we believe, I believe,
that if you create more meaningful work
and people focus on insights and action
and less on Excel and PowerPoint and Word,
then there is a chance
that they enjoy their work more.
Now it may lead to productivity gains,
it may lead to efficiency.
It may lead to all those things,
nobody's sort of denying that.
But what I've discovered
so far is when it does,
people see it quite quickly
and they put their hand up
to do something else,
or to focus more on insights
than ... data crunching
and aggregation.
You know, I'm old enough to remember
when the internet was launched,
you know, commercially.
And it's sort of similar arguments,
even when the cell phone was launched.
"Be careful."
But the truth is,
they made all our lives better.
The use cases are coming.
But I think we're starting
to understand now
how much this is going to change
everybody's lives.
LL: So who is leading this
in the organization?
Is it a new generation?
Is it specially appointed people?
Where's the leadership coming from?
PH: It's an excellent question
because maybe I'm the last
of the great dinosaur CEOs
who got to the top
by doing sort of every job.
I ran Japan, I ran North America,
you know, I was in global marketing.
You know, I've done all the tasks,
to get to the top,
and then I've sort of seen everything.
And so I can be involved
in every discussion.
And now the younger talent are saying,
"You didn't see AI, old man."
So, you know, "I have a better
insight than you do."
And "Oh, and by the way, I'm not just
going to push it up to my boss,
I'd like to tell you myself."
LL: Right.
PH: So the younger talent,
justifiably is saying,
"Hey," you know, "I don't need to have
my work shared upwards
by a bunch of guys
who are all sitting there
going, 'What do you think?'
and none of them actually know."
And so we invert the pyramid.
We have to have different
people with two, three,
four years experience in the room.
Because what do we know?
And that's sort of exciting,
I think, really exciting.
LL: So is AI a unique disruptor?
If we think about some of the other
big challenges, you know,
we've got to shift the entire global
economy to be sustainable, for example.
Is that comparable in terms of complexity?
Maybe more so?
How do you tackle that kind of an issue?
PH: I think these are the big
transformational moments for society.
And, you know, sustainability is,
you know, for many,
it was carbon neutrality,
then it was net zero,
it was go to COP 28,
it was put a poster by the elevator
with the meaningful work you're doing
to show your commitment.
But it's really different now.
I think there's a collective realization,
certainly in healthcare,
that we didn't do well enough.
And we're a very
purpose-driven organization --
an industry, in fact.
We do health,
we transform the practice of medicine,
we invent miracles often.
And so it's very easy to say,
look, we're very purpose-driven.
But it doesn't abdicate the responsibility
of removing plastic from packaging
of vaccines and medicines.
It's ridiculous to even think
you wouldn't have to.
Often it's harder with the regulator,
by the way, to get that done
than with your own people.
LL: So you've got those kinds
of projects going on, have you?
Can you give us an example?
PH: We have to do it.
We have to do it because, you know,
we have this sort of approach
of what can we do
that if we don't do, it won't happen?
And that's sort of our philosophy.
You know, in healthcare,
it's a good example,
you know, delivery of healthcare
creates more carbon
than the airline industry.
And that's half of that,
let's say five percent.
Half of that is making drugs,
shipping them, doing different things.
The other half is people driving
to hospitals for an appointment
in an overheated, overcooled
healthcare practice, too often,
without the use of a virtual
hybrid delivery of healthcare.
And it's the same as the airline industry.
And, you know, we feel,
because we're in healthcare,
we have this unique opportunity.
If somebody is pre-diabetic, for example,
and you coach them
and they change their lifestyle
and don't become a diabetic,
that's a difference of them
creating 16 tons of carbon
as a normal adult, healthy,
and 48 tons of carbon in their adult life
if they become diabetic.
That's a 3X.
That's really meaningful.
And if we don't step in and help,
we just simply never get there
and we're doing a lot of work,
I'm doing a lot of work with King Charles
and the Sustainable Markets Initiative
to get people to decarbonize
the delivery of healthcare,
because it's such a massive opportunity.
LL: And presumably you've got
to collaborate in very different ways
than in the past to do, you know,
you're talking about supply chains
to deal with something like plastic.
Are you seeing different kinds
of skills from people
in order to make those collaborations?
PH: Well, I think these functions
and the sustainability groups, as I said,
have come from a poster by the elevator
to being very actively involved in a lot
of work to do these things properly.
And, you know, you, it's not
about a competitive advantage,
in Sanofi being better
at wastewater management
or renewable energy
than Pfizer or AstraZeneca.
That's not a competition.
The competition is us versus,
you know, destroying the planet.
So we work a lot together
to do the right thing.
I work with Novo Nordisk, AstraZeneca, GSK
to try and work out ways
to be kinder to the environment
in the delivery of health,
and it's the right thing to do, right?
It's a shared responsibility,
a collective responsibility.
LL: And we're talking here
about big social challenges
beyond any one business
or industry or even country,
with an expectation that business
needs to step forward.
I think partly driven by the fact
that policy doesn't always work,
and we're disappointed with leadership
and with government.
So a lot of finger pointing
as to who's responsible
and who can act on these big shifts.
I wonder how ambitious and bold
do you feel CEOs should be
about stepping forward
and helping society through some
of these mega transitions
that we are faced with?
PH: You know, it's clear
that companies are being pulled more
into the conversation
about individual's values.
And I think people
who work in our company,
and all companies,
start to try and identify
themselves, perhaps rightly,
with the values of the company.
And they're starting to have
much higher expectations
about the company they work for.
And it can be on all
the major social issues.
You know, there's been so many difficult
moments and tragic moments.
I'm often written to by people
from all over the world.
"You haven't declared which side
you're on on this important subject.
Why not?"
And people want to know
that you are fully vested
and the company is behind them.
To be clear, it's almost impossible
to get everything right.
The world is almost,
you know, perfectly divided.
You can pick an issue and half
your employees will tell you
"We don't agree," and the other
half will say, "Well done."
And we're not used to that as CEOs,
we're used to trying to find
the right sort of moment
to get the majority to say,
"I'm proud of my company."
So you have to retreat
a little bit and say,
I'll spend my energy on making sure
whatever the issue, that the people,
90,000 people in our case,
get the very best chance to live
their best version of themselves.
Could be inclusion, it could be race,
it could be many different things.
It could be LGBTQ-plus.
But whatever those issues
that are being debated strongly
or less strongly in different
parts of the world,
it matters to us that our people feel
they can be the best
version of themselves.
So when people ask,
"What do you think about this?"
"What do you think about that?"
I can have a personal opinion,
but our organization,
if you're looking to match
your values with ours,
is really about, we're in healthcare,
we want you to have
the best life possible.
How can the company facilitate that
in this sort of, maelstrom of subjects?
And we focus then --
I'm not saying we're perfect,
I don't think any company really
is perfect on this,
but the expectation of our own employees
to be able to set a standard on an issue
and to see it through is real.
And leading in these times
is more complicated, I think,
than perhaps it has been previously.
LL: So you're describing a world
where the work of the CEO
is changing very fast.
Could you just sum up for us
the role of a leader in this new era?
PH: Well, I took this role
at the end of 2019 and thought,
I will roll through my 100-day plan
and I will amble through getting around
town halls across the world
and shake a lot of hands
and do a listening tour.
And a pandemic dropped on us
within a few weeks after that
and worked out of the kitchen
not far from here.
And the war, Russia-Ukraine,
current war, Israel and Hamas,
and mentioned the pandemic.
China-US, the social issues.
And I think what we realize is leading
is I think somebody described it
as the perma crisis, you know,
a sort of, you know, a cadence of issues
that just is relentless.
And you really have to have some
resiliency leading now, I think,
and you have to recognize that there are
a series of sprints in the role.
There's the fundamentals of the business
that must be continued.
Then there's a metronome for us.
We feel a responsibility
to bring medicines
and transformational medicines
forward is non-negotiable.
At the same time,
parts of your organization
is in a very difficult situation
somewhere in the world.
And we have to make sure
we have the right energy, experts,
support, crisis teams, often,
more recently
to protect our people
and to continue the work we do.
We ship drugs all over the world,
irrespective of the stance of politics
or anything else.
People are people
and if they're sick we'll help.
But it really has got very complicated.
So resiliency, agility
and being open-minded,
recognizing you're not
the expert many times,
trusting the advice you get
from your own people,
particularly those on the ground,
protecting your people
where it's necessary,
moving your people where it's necessary.
That's the sort of new
expectation, really.
LL: I mean, I think we're all experiencing
this sense of perma crisis.
Just to finish,
it would be great to just get a sense
of what are you really
excited about right now?
PH: Well, I'm incredibly excited,
I touched on it at the beginning
about the use of artificial intelligence,
particularly large language models.
Because I think it changes everything.
It's got me questioning
whether I can go back
and look at medicines
that didn't quite make it,
and wonder if we just didn't know enough
with the data that we had
to look deep enough.
It can be, you know,
recently we just did our --
this is a small example,
but it's just fun,
our engagement survey,
we had a 409,000 comments,
9 million words.
And normally, somebody
would make a nice slide deck
to tell me, "The organization poll
is very engaged.
Never been more engaged."
"How much more engaged?" "0.1."
"OK, good, thank you."
Definitely improvement.
And so I asked them
to run the 409,000 comments
through a large language model.
Forty minutes later, it told me
the three things
that people love about the company
and three things
that people hate about it.
I didn't need a lot of external support,
didn't need teams of people.
And it was clear, it was no hallucination,
because it was there right in front of me.
And it made sense.
And I shared them with people
and they're like, yeah, that's us.
And I think that's the difference
between meaningful work
using -- let's talk about what it tells us
about whether our people
really like it here
and bring their best or not.
I think AI for me, a relatively new CEO,
I have a chance to disrupt structural
biology, electron microscopy,
I have a chance to invent medicines
and druggable targets
that were never touched before.
I have a chance to take away the sort of,
I should put it, the heavy lifting,
unglamorous work
that people don't like doing.
I've a chance to reinvent everything,
to do it more efficiently,
reinvest in R and D.
And I have a chance to get ahead
of the competition
while they're all worrying,
we have governance,
but every step forward by us
is a step of leaving behind
those that are overly sensitive,
and we're happy to share.
But we can do incredible
things for patients
and for the people in the company
by being more bold
about stepping into the new world.
LL: Your passion is infectious.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Paul.
PH: Thank you.
(Applause)